l' affaire grégory christine villemin ne
sera pas jugée dans les vosges mais à
dijon en côte-d'or peut-être aux assises
de cette ville ainsi en a décidé la cour
de cassation aujourd'hui un nouvel
épisode dans cette ténébreuse affaire
paul lefèvre après trois heures de
délibéré la chambre criminelle de la
cour de cassation a rendu son arrêt à
retenir trois choses d'abord
l'annulation de trois éléments de
l'accusation important pour certains
mais non essentiels pour au dossier
ensuite la désignation de la chambre
d'accusation de dijon pour compléter la
procédure
enfin et c'est la surprise la
désignation de la cour d'assises de
dijon pour éjecter in villemin je vous
rappelle au départ les avocats de
christine villemin avait présenté à la
cour de cassation dit moyens
d'annulation dont plusieurs concernés
le rapport d'autopsié du corps de
l'enfant l'annulation de ce rapport
d'autopsié aurait signifié en réalité la
fin sans procès de l'affairé villemin
la cour de cassation a maintenu cette
pièce essentielle du dossier mais a
suivi l'avocat général françois rabut
qui demandait que christine villemin ne
soit pas jugé à epinal afin d'éviter les
passions de cette affaire qui n'est dit
il est un gâchis de justice